I'm skating with these women I feel on
fire I love roller skating so much that
I decided that I was going to bring it
back for everyone I'm a South Island
better known as Esther then and I'm the
founder of Moxie roller skates there are
21 skaters on the mossy skating
worldwide but some of them are pigeon
Indy Jimmy Jones smelly and with legs
anything that's experimental or outside
of what you've probably seen on roller
skates is what we do roller skating was
really really big until I was born and
then it really kind of dropped off when
rollerblades came in roller skate
innovation just stopped
roller derby was the next new court to
come to the roller skating industry to
see that they were selling the roller
derby skaters were made for speed the
skates that we're making now are made
for secure landings for high flying
trick you know a few years ago there
were clicks Cal doing backflips and on
their own wheel and now there are and
I'm amazed at what my body can do I
really am
we are chasing our dreams we're chasing
that feeling that wonderful slow be
feeling of being alive and you you will
get that firm Rollerson it's a strange
new feeling it's refreshing oh this
dress
I think that in the skateboarding
culture you get a lot of people in
general that are different the emerges
kids that want to place them on being in
their own place doing everybody else's
today Chris Worley is the founder of a
skate a nonprofit that teaches kids with
autism how to skateboard autism has a
lot of aspects to it most of the kids
need occupational therapy of some forms
skateboarding is similar to other
therapies they're learning how to
control our body in motion and it just
simulates parts of the brain that need
to be stimulated in order to do things
in life in order to have conversations
in order to pay attention
I have a son who will soon be 14 his
name is Sasha and he was diagnosed with
autism at 22 months old I bought him for
skateboard when he was right at five
years old his brother was three it was
really difficult for them to just come
together and play there was no play
somehow the movement of the skateboard
just made him focus and they which is
gauged and I want to do that for other
family Kris started a skate eight years
ago in a church parking lot in
Birmingham Alabama it sent expanded
across the US and internationally this
year they were invited to participate in
the Dew Tour a pro skating contest in
California where kids were paired with
professional skateboarders I've known
Sasha since I got involved with a skate
about five years ago the joy that I see
that it brings to kids like that's where
I know that this is what I'm supposed to
be doing the skateboarding culture is
accepting of everyone in our spectrum or
not spectrum no one cares what color
pipe gender whatever it is like you can
stay you can stay and we got love for
you really incredible to see kids change
through our
I see families just see their child who
is now capable of something and they
didn't know it in a way forming a skate
is like a love letter to Sasha
he may never understand that or know it
but I do kind of like a skater has a
skateboarder BMX pair has a bike I just
saw the wheelchair something fun so why
not take it into the park I'm Erin
wheels bothering him and I ride w CM x w
CM X stands for wheelchair motocross
it's you know taking your chair into the
skate park and hitting ramps kind of the
same thing as BMX but with a wheelchair
I first started going to the skate parks
when I was eight years old and I've been
doing it for 16 years now the wheelchair
is definitely just an extension of my
body because skaters aren't always on
their skateboard and bikers aren't
always on their bike but I'm always on
my chair so that gives me like an unfair
advantage to just practice everywhere I
go I feel like I'm lucky that I always
have my wheelchair with me because I can
just jump whenever I want I was born
with spina bifida I've had 21 surgeries
throughout my life and I spent a lot of
time in the hospitals and yeah it would
be easy to just be bummed out on that
but I was for me I just found the
positive the wheelchairs just always
been fun and it's wheels stuck to your
butt how's that not a great time
in 2008 I got the Guinness world record
for the first backflip on a wheelchair
now is that a local competition here in
Vegas called am Jim that was a pretty
cool day one of my favorite tricks is
just simple hand flip because I always
loved watching skaters do it when I was
growing up and you know watching the
pros do it it just was something I
wanted to learn
[Music]
I'm very blessed to be able to do what I
love and what I'm passionate about for a
living a lot of the time the wheelchair
comes with the stereotype of you can't
do this or whatever because it's a
medical device
I just always turn the wheelchair is a
great opportunity I feel like there's
like a glass ceiling for women because
I've hit it if you skate any risk then
you should just get what you deserve
it's like skateboarding is supposed to
be for everybody if we do actually want
any form of equality or space like we're
going to have to be going to create that
space
my name is Lacey Baker and I'm a
professional skateboarder I discovered
skateboarding when I was really really
young like two years old I was in foster
care at that time and I would watch my
foster brothers escape a mini-ramp
and I just like immediately obsessed
like I was like I have to do this I
started competing when I was 11 years
old when I was 22 I skated the 2014 X
Games in Austin and that's the year I
won the gold with women and papering
there's like a subculture within a
subculture so ski industry like just
doesn't care about women's skating it's
not equal for example like there is a
skateboard contest series which didn't
used to include women in it but it just
started to however is no prize for first
place is 30 grand family for the guys
first place is 200
I feel like it should be equal to me
work just as hard again male skateboards
is a company that was created to like
support women in skateboarding I do my
own board graphics like I do a lot of
the other girls board graphics and like
it's rad because it's like skater owned
and it's like for us and it's like
bhaiyya so it's like there's nothing
corporate about it and it feels like
like that's how it's supposed to be even
if nothing comes of like like having
asked a career or like anything like
that like I still have skating and like
I believe in being yourself and like you
know just doing whatever the [ __ ] you
want that's what skating is supposed to
be
[Music]